today we have an insane plot league for
it one of the most anticipated Disney
Plus shows coming to the MCU for phase
four Falcon and the Winter Soldier how's
it going everybody it's Warren and I
know a lot of people are really really
excited for the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier series coming to Disney Plus and
if you are one of those people
this plot link is going to get you even
more excited and if you're not that
excited about it perhaps this plot link
could get you excited about it because
this plot leaked does talk about the
return of a certain Captain America
played by a certain Chris Evans along
with other plot details such as the main
villain and how exactly Sam and Bucky
come together for this series I'll be
covering many exciting things in this
plot leak so be sure to stick around
until the end also don't forget to
subscribe to my channel I'm giving away
an xbox one or a ps4 the winner gets to
decide I'm picking a new winner at five
hundred and fifty thousand subscribers
all you have to do to enter is subscribe
like the video and comment below with
your favorite superhero or villain so
like with all plot leaks that we get
disclaimer take it with a grain of salt
this is coming from 4chan and reddit as
well but sounds very legitimate and the
way it picks up after Avengers in game
expect sense and the way it ties in all
of the previous existing characters and
the MCU makes perfect sense as well so
let's dive right into it the first part
of this leak says Thunderbolt Ross
William Hurt of course and the
government does not want Sam Wilson to
be the new Captain America due to him
not signing the accords now of course
this is referring to the scovia cords
that were in Captain America Civil War
and of course as we know Sam was siding
with Captain America and did not sign
the accords during a civil war he was
thrown in jail and of course we know
that at the end Captain America broke
him out and from there on up until the
events of Avengers in game we know that
Captain America Sam and Natasha were off
doing their own secret missions but of
course this whole entire time they were
wanted this is why Thunderbolt Ross
tells Rhodey to arrest them when they
show up in Avengers end game now
considering the fact that Sam helps save
the world
I'm sure he's not wanted anymore but he
was still a wanted fugitive that did not
sign the sokovia accords so it would
make sense that the government would not
want Sam Wilson who was a few
to be the new Captain America the image
of Captain America is supposed to be
this clean-cut good behaved guy and a
fugitive is not that so what did they do
this leak says they enlist John Walker
to be the new Captain America who
prefers to go by the name u.s. agent now
I reported this leak a very long time
ago maybe around five to six months ago
there was talks about US agent being in
Falcon and the Winter Soldier and at the
time the rumors were saying that John
Cena was in talks to play US agent
however sadly there is no confirmation
that John Cena will be playing at US
agent but since John Walker is announced
the new Captain America Sam is furious
and he gets the help of Bucky Barnes to
help him fight low-level crimes now of
course he's furious at the end of
Avengers in game he had his big moment
where Steve Rogers passed down the
shield and the mantle of Captain America
down to Sam and in that moment Sam
became Captain America which was
obviously a very huge deal his best
friend and probably Idol Captain America
passed the mantle down to him and now
they're saying that he cannot be Captain
America now this sort of follows the
storylines from the comics however in
the comics when the mantle of Captain
America is supposed to be passed down to
Sam the government says no because they
don't think America is ready for a black
Captain America now obviously this is
not the route they're going with Falcon
and the Winter Soldier but it does kind
of follow a similar storyline where Sam
is supposed to be Captain America but
the government says no so Sam gets mad
and he gets the help of Bucky to help
him fight low-level crimes but at the
same time Sharon Carter who of course is
played by Emily VanCamp who of course we
knew was going to be in the series begs
the government to replace Walker with
Sam but Sam and Bucky grow close with
Walker as Sam has accepted Walker as the
new Captain America so sadly it seems
like Sam is not going to be Captain
America immediately going into the
series however that may not last long
because according to this leak Walker
gets a chip in his brain and planted by
Baron Zemo of course played by Daniel
Bruhl resulting in Walker going rogue
now again this kind of follows a similar
story from the comics when Walker
becomes Captain America in the comics
he's not really
like the old Captain America he's kind
of a radicalist and he can't be
controlled so by them putting a chip in
his brain is kind of the same thing of
having him not being able to be
controlled and go rogue
but zimas plans don't just stop at being
able to control us
agent / Captain America / John Walker
his plans are to put these chips into
every single person in the entire
population and he gets the help of
Rachel Layton to help him execute his
plan now for those of you who do not
know who Rachel Layton is she is
primarily known by her name Diamondback
and Diamondback has a direct connection
to crossbones taskmaster Captain America
and the serpent society now when
Diamondback started off she was
originally in a gang led by a man known
as Bing Bing would later on become the
character that everybody knows as
crossbones now it has been said before
anything was confirmed about Baron Zemo
returning to the Falcon and Winter
Soldier series that crossbones could
make an appearance as well and Baron
Zemo beam-in Falcon and the winter
soldiers ended up being true so
crossbones could make a return as well
even though he died in Captain America
Civil War but perhaps somebody else
could have picked up the mantle but
Diamondback was one of the original
members of the serpent society and a lot
of us fans have been expecting some kind
of Captain America serpent Society story
for a pretty long time now and it seems
like we're going to get somewhat of that
story in the Falcon and Winter Soldier
series just with Sam as Captain America
eventually but the interesting thing
about diamondback is that in her first
encounter with Captain America in the
comics she instantly falls in love with
him so if Sam is going to be the new
Captain America perhaps she could fall
in love with Sam and it is worth noting
that Captain America does eventually
fall in love with her as well and
Diamondback eventually turns her back on
the serpent Society
so Baron Zemo wants to implant these
chips and all of the population and he
gets the help of diamondback to do so
Thunderbolt Ross and the government are
now desperate so what do they do they
hire Sam and Bucky to go and stop Walker
alfre woodard as Mirim shape and Martin
Freeman as ever at Ross return in major
roles which makes perfect sense because
Martin Freeman as Everett Ross is said
to return for Black Panther too as well
and here's really the big news that
everybody has been waiting for this leak
says that Chris Evans as old Steve
Rogers will appear in two episodes
possibly to give moral advice to Sam and
Bucky now this is something that
everybody wants to see and it's
something that makes perfect sense now
we know there's somewhat of a debate
between the writers and the directors of
Avengers in game on whether or not
Captain America exists in the main MCU
timeline or not but at the end of
Avengers in game old man Steve Rogers
was in the main MCU timeline so whether
or not he was in that timeline the whole
time or just travel to that timeline we
can assume that he could stick around
for a little bit and his fate was not
the same as Tony starts he didn't die
he's simply old but Captain America is
one to give advice especially to his
friends and it would make sense that Sam
and Bucky get in a little bit over their
heads in this it would really be their
first time without Captain America there
to call the shots they are now in
control so maybe even it's the two of
them that seek out the guidance from old
man Steve Rogers and let's remember that
Marvel is to an extent about pleasing
their fans they don't write stories in
movies specifically to please fans but a
cameo from Chris Evans as old man
Captain America in the Falcon and Winter
Soldier series is something that
everybody would absolutely love and
something that Marvel could do it would
definitely have a good impact and it
wouldn't offset anything he did in
Avengers in game this would not be like
bringing Tony Stark back if you bring
Tony Stark back you take away his
sacrifice but Steve Rogers simply
retired and him coming back to give
advice to his two old best friends
doesn't take away anything from that so
according to this leak it seems like we
could see Captain America in two
episodes of Falcon and the Winter
Soldier series and then the leak ends by
saying Yelena Bulova and Emil Blonsky
are expected to cameo sometime in the
series and this makes perfect sense
because it would tie the Falcon in the
Winter Soldier series into the Black
Widow movie that is coming up and it's
widely believed that Yelena Bulova is
going to be the new Black Widow moving
forward in the MCU so it would make
sense that they would connect the series
to the movie Plus not to mention we know
that taskmaster is going to be the
villain of Black Widow and Diamondback
was trained at one a taskmaster Zack at
so this would link Falcon and the Winter
Soldier series to Black Widow in a
couple of different ways and of course
that's what Marvel loves to do it's the
MCU it's all interconnected so if this
plot leaked ends up being true we're
looking at one heck of a series many
characters would be returning such as
Sharon Carter Thunderbolt Ross Baron
Zemo
Miriam shape Everett Ross and Captain
America old Man Captain America Steve
Rogers but still Captain America so this
could turn out to be an incredible show
but let me know what you think about
this plot leak is this something you
would like to see in the Falcon and
Winter Soldier series on Disney Plus and
would you be excited to see Steve Rogers
return as old man Captain America in
this series let me know all your
thoughts about this in the comments down
below and don't forget to like this
video and subscribe to my channel so you
can have a chance to win an Xbox one for
a ps4 again all you have to do to enter
is be subscribed like the video and
comment with your favorite superhero or
villain I'm also starting a giveaway on
Twitter and Instagram soon so be sure to
follow me on there and as always thank
you all so much for watching woof woof